あけまして　おめでとうございます
新年早々 突然 ですが
私はじめしゃちょーから重大なお知らせがございます
私　はじめしゃちょー2019年1月15日をもちまして
結婚
いたしません
せん　せん　せん　てかできんできん　したいしたいしたい　できればしたいでもできんきん　できんできん
はっは　できんしたいしたい　もうアラサ―×２
失礼 致し まし た 今年 の
縛り プレイ の 話 です 皆 さん 明け まし て お めでとう ござい ます と いう わけ で やっ て まいり まし た ね
2019 年 いつから 始まっ て しまっ た ん だろう 俺 の 縛り プレイ 俺 は 1 年 に 1度 必ず
何か 縛り を 入れ て 生活 し てきた　お菓子好きすぎてお菓子を禁止し始めたのが
2016 年 2016 年 に お 菓子 禁止 なん か その ノリ で
なん か もっと やっ て みよう と 思っ て 禁止 し た の は ラーメン そして 2018 年 去年 2018 年
俺 は ハードル を 上げ に 上げ
肉 を
1 年間 禁止 し た ちなみ に 今 な ん です けど
ちなみ に 今 1 月 1 日 の 6 時5 分 な ん です けど も まだ お 肉 は 食べ て おり ませ ん
もったい なく て 食べれてないんですよ お 肉食べるのは また 別 の 動画 で し て　とりあえずもう
今年 の 縛り プレイ を 始め ちゃおう か な と 思い まし て
まあ いろいろ 考え たら お菓子禁止 し ラーメン 禁止 し そしてお肉も禁止し いろいろ 考え まし た ただ 俺 は
この 3 つ の 禁止 を し て き て ある重大なこと に 気づい て しまっ た そう
食べ物 を 禁止 する の は
Heart　（ハート） 良く ない そう
お 肉 を 禁止 し て思った
まあ
いいや
お肉禁止関係 は ちょっと 別 の 動画 で 話し ます　だけどこのまま引き続き あの 今 まで 通り 頑張っ て いく の で
よろしく お 願い 致し ます で ここ で な ん です けど も まぁ 縛り プレイ の 話 です 皆 さん気になってる でしょ
これ 以上 先 の 縛り プレイ に どんな もの が ある の か 皆 さん 分からんだろそこ で 私
考え に 考え 決め まし た
今年一年間の縛りプレイの内容発表いたします
私　はじめしゃちょーは　今年一年
スーツしか着ません
今年一年私スーツしか
着ません
食べ物 の 禁止 は ね ちょっと もう 飽き た 食べ物 を 禁止 し て も いい ことねえ ただただ 何 か 変 な この モヤモヤ
がたまるんで
もっと ねーえかな なんて 思っ て いろいろ 調べ たり 考え たり 意見 を 聞い たり し た ん です けどもたどり着いた結果
あれ？　スーツ 1 年 き て みる と いい ん じゃ ねっ て 思っ た わけ です スーツ 1 年着る 理由 その 1
初心 にかえれる　 皆様
ユーチューバーたるもの 謝罪動画 というものを よく 上げ ます もちろん 僕 も 挙げ た こと あり ます謝罪動画
を 撮る 時 大抵 の ユーチューバー さん は スーツ を 着 て いる ん です あれ なぜ か と 言い ます と誠心誠意
心を表しているから スーツ を 着 て いる ん です 真心 を 込め て 動画 を 撮っ て いる それ 果たして
謝罪 動画 だけ で いい の か みんなー！ 謝罪 動画 だけ スーツ で ある 必要 は あり ませ ん
ご覧 ください社会人 の皆様 常 に スーツ を 着 て い ます
まあ、会社 に よっ て です けど スーツというものはやはり こう、精神誠意の真心を表す
あの、大切 な 正装 で ございます謝罪 動画 だけでなく 常 に 日頃 の 動画 から
精神誠意 動画 を 取る と 気持ち を 忘れ ない初心の心 を 忘れ ない ため に も 真心 込め て動画づくり
初心 忘れ ない 大切 な 登録 者 0人の時の 気持ち神聖な気持ち を 忘れ ず に 動画 を 撮る
ため に は 心 から 変わら なけれ ば いけ ない　心を変えるもの
まず は 服装 から と いうわけでで 1 年 スーツ を 着 て み ます よろしく お 願い 致し ます 理由その２
スーツ を 着 て いる ユーチューバー が 少ない 多分 い ます よ
全然 探し たら いる と 思う ん です けど も なんか僕 の知っている同じ よう な ことしてる
ユーチューバー さん の 中 で スーツ を 着 て 動画 を 撮っ てる 人 が い なかっ た ん で あれこれ チャンス じゃ ね と
思っ て あの スーツ を 着 て み ますやっぱ 目立っ て なんぼ の 世界 な ん で ちょっと こう なんか ね
目指し たい ん ですよやべ、理由が2 つ しか ない
まあ いいでしょ　理由なんて どう で も いい ん です 1年間 これ を する こと に 意味 が ある
というわけで 縛りの内容 ちょっと軽～く まとめ て おき まし た
あの動画 を 撮る 時 は スーツ を 着 て 普通 に 会社 行く よう な 感じ な ん でただ僕 なんか は
大抵 動画 撮っ てる ん でたぶんほぼ私服 も スーツ に なり ます
ずーっと この服です　 でもね 社会人 の 人 はね、この 服 を毎日着て 頑張っ てる わけ です から 大丈夫 です
僕もでき ます。 って か その気持ちが 大事 な ん です やっ て みせましょう 今年 一 年　　っていうかやっぱり
実験系とか、なんかこう イメージ の ある 服装 の 時 ある と 思う ん です よ
撮影 に 応じ た 服装 に は 変える こと が できる ん です が 私服 的 な 服 の とき は 必ず
スーツ を 今年 1 年着用 さ せ て いただき ます
すいません。でもあの 去年撮った動画今年 まだ 出 て ない の が あっ たり する ん で 私服の 動画 が
ちょっと 1 月 中 は出ちゃったり する か も しれ ないっす　 けどあの 許し て くださいというわけで 今年 一 年
身 も 心 も リフレッシュ し精神誠意動画 を 真剣 に 作る ため に　スーツで
頑張らせていただきます じゃあな！
♪～